[Music]
it's going to tell us about unsupervised
learning okay make sure you ask him
about I I'm very excited it's Friday
afternoon I'm talking to people who
probably I'm going to waste their time
and I'm following Chris ptosis talks so
what could be better
okay so unsupervised learning and what
do we mean by that data and the data has
no labels and you'd like to understand
it find some patterns in it make use of
it maybe understand what data to collect
there are many extensions to this but
I'll restrict myself to really no labels
data with no labels you could have
semi-supervised interactive lifelong
learning where you're transferring
concepts from one to the other and
they're all very interesting more recent
but yeah and there are basically two
high level approaches to learning this
clustering you want to take your data
and group it into similar things that
are dissimilar from the groups are
dissimilar well this sort of the high
level approaches that we that have gone
into play have been analyzed you pick an
objective function or some other quality
measure and try to optimize it and the
other approach is is model fitting well
you hypothesize a model for the data
could be deterministic or probabilistic
the latter are more common and then the
goal of the algorithm is to estimate
parameters of this model
and then if the parameters you come up
with are much less likely then than
those of a random model in this class
you're considering then maybe maybe it's
something interesting so that's the
that's the second approach these are the
two five-dollar produce okay so there
are many challenges and issues here and
understanding this you know first yes
the data is labeled but you still need
some domain knowledge and insight to
define the right problem if you're going
after an objective function what what
makes sense and many of you might have
seen these examples where if you try one
objective you get a very different
clustering than a different objective
and so on and then you know their
addition so we like generalize problems
with mathematical appeal so this can be
an issue if you won't have nevertheless
some beautiful problems and techniques
have emerged and that's what I'm going
to focus on what's probably worked a few
examples of things that have probably
worked in this field many of these ideas
and algorithms successful ones in
machine learning are due to
neuroscientists we already saw some in
the in in in the morning stocks
perceptron for example I will see some
more there's a lot to understand and of
course one of the one of the issues is
how is the brain learning you could
argue that much of it is unsurprised and
we're not telling the kids to do some
objective function yet the code from
Lacan that Christos mentioned is he says
that the revolution will not be
surprised so I'd say it's a talking you
so yeah okay now there in addition to
these meta approaches there are also
meta methods you might call principal
component analysis we'll see several
slides on this or we didn't prove about
it k-means is an algorithm that you use
all the time when you don't have labels
expectation-maximization yeah gradient
descent suddenly and so on and the nice
thing about this is that you can just
use one of them right away or
almost on many datasets so it's great
but then are they actually working will
they converge
what will they converge to when why
these are all questions that are open
for the most part and certainly in
supervised learning as well okay so here
here are the examples I picked mixture
models independent component analysis
finding planted structures graph
clustering and some snippets from
computer science attempts at
understanding bits of neuroscience okay
there are many other interesting models
some of which might be relevant to this
semester such as learning discrete
distributions hidden Markov models and
I'm mentioning the ones on which there's
been interesting and and surprising
progress learning dictionaries you know
we we saw a very brief introduction to
sparse coding in Brianna's talk
yesterday that that has led lots of work
internal computer science identifying
relevant features and so on last area so
mixture models what our mixture models
the classical so just to give a sense
only if you already know what a mixture
model is and so think of the data as
points in space so you're seeing a bunch
of data each one there's a point in
space so it's measured various things
and you see these points and you want to
know is the data coming perhaps from a
mixture of a small number of nice
distributions the nicest distributions
between general recipients you can think
of for calcium's
so is your data in very high dimensions
so this dimension is super high right
and but maybe there are just K gaussians
I've drawn to that explain it that that
if the data is really drawn from those
or something very close to that that's
what you'd like to know
so hypothesize that it is coming from
mixture model and then the problem is to
find them
so given samples without so you're not
being told so you get to you erase the
the actual these boundaries that I've
drawn and then you want to know you know
toward what's the mixture it's coming
from so what do I mean by a mixture
there is a set of underlying
distributions or relate perhaps a little
small number of them okay and then each
of them has a weight so that's the
probability that the sample is coming
from the first one the second one so
these weights are non-negative add up to
one
and so each component is so I will
assume Gaussian for the stock but it
could be more general this problem goes
back over a hundred years it was applied
to real data to classify species and the
two variants of the problem you would
consider the first is classification
where you really want to separate the
points according to which Gaussian they
came from the the component of origin
now that one needs some separation right
so even in one dimension if you had this
Gaussian and this Gaussian you will
certainly not be able to uniquely
identify points that are in the overlap
region so if you want to be able to do
that you need some separation and then
you might be able to classify most of
them correctly now you then it at first
glance it might seem or the problem
should be easy if they're going to be
separated you'll be able to tell them
apart that's fine in one dimension it is
easy in one dimension if they're
separated but when you go to high
dimension most pairs of points are
roughly at the same distance so you know
for this type of naive approach to work
we'll see in a minute you need a very
large separation much larger then
actually you information theoretically
need to say tutorial to realize they're
they're separated but the other variant
is learning what I what I mean ok so
they overlap so what I just I still want
to learn the parameters what are the
means and the standard deviations of
these gaussians I don't care if the olla
then you might ask is that problem even
well-defined you know maybe there are
multiple mixtures which X which arises
give rise to the same data and that
fortunately is not possible for
gaussians gaussian mixtures are uniquely
if you give me two descriptions of
parameters which have different in some
part maybe one of the means is different
or one of the bearings is different or
one of the mixing weight is different
then there's a there's a unique fit to
it so that's nice a piece of problem is
solvable in principle and indeed there
is a polynomial algorithm to learn a
mixture of gaussians up to any desired
accuracy this for two guys since it was
done Michael I'm ultra valiant and
Wilkinson ha and then generalized to
Hagar since unfortunately the sample
complexity grows exponentially with the
number of components we know that it
must grow at least as 2 to the K this
was in a paper by the two younger
graduates and also in the original paper
but but even more perhaps there is a
lower bound that suggests that at least
for lots of known algorithms including
the ones that are used to solve is upper
bound you need at least n to the K
samples now the reason I'm pointing this
out is another nice thing that
complexity can tell us is yes n is the
dimension K is the number of gussets
this is the total number of samples that
this algorithm needs and you need at
least 2 to the K for for just
information 30 reasons otherwise you
won't be able to tell them apart but
turns out that if you only consider
statistical query algorithms will I
might mention them a little bit later
there are a class of algorithms that
includes things like PCA and stochastic
optimization convex optimization and so
on
then you need n to the N to the case
with less than is reasonably clever okay
great yeah what what is the complexity
so it's a kind of ornament okay but we
use will say compression techniques so
we pick the points or compression
representation of the gauss's so there
is some extra assumption on information
being given yeah okay
so it remains open so this could be
useful for a small number of components
and whether the true complexity is
polynomially and then k is still an open
question in both N and K polynomial in n
times function of K thank you yeah
polynomial in n times function of K
that's I remove the question that was on
slide is there a polynomial in n times
function of K algorithm first problem
yeah
now techniques and maybe maybe this
apply more generally than this
particular problem the first one is
random projection you see it everywhere
and machine learning now the idea was
only about that scoop that was you take
this mixture of these points that are
very high dimension and project them
down to a low much lower dimensional
space and then in that lower dimensional
space let's just use some kind of
distance based separation we'll get back
to then now the the one nice thing about
projection is that it will preserve the
distances between most pairs or it'll
scale them all down proportionally in
particular if the means of these
gaussians were separated they will
remain separated by or at least they're
there they will remain proportionally
separated that's not enough to solve
this problem however this idea
originally due to kalaiy and that was
used in in these papers is the following
so you have this this mixture in in high
dimension I'm going to project it so so
we make no assumption on separation now
it's
just a mixture of gaussians points from
a mixture of batteries somewhere up
there when projected to a randomly
chosen line one dimensional projection
projector into randomly chosen line well
you know gaussians projected out since
the projections are still Gaussian so
you're going to get some mixture of
gaussians whatever they are now if I
could let's assume that I can solve the
problem in 1d 1 DK gaussians we know
they are uniquely identifiable let's
assume we can solve it in polynomial in
yeah in any certainly this it's not ok
now okay so you've got something about
this you know which projection you
applied you apply the particular
projection matrix R 1 you've got this
data you've learned the means well
that's to do it again and again
note for a whole bunch of projections
for each of them now you're getting a
system of equations right because the
original means are getting projected and
you know what the projection mean is the
original means getting projected no the
projection means you've got a whole
bunch of equations if you've got enough
you can solve them almost there not
quite because we don't know which mean
corresponds to which gas every time you
do it it could flip so so the idea is it
is let's just take one random line but
then we consider a few lines that are
slight perturbations of it and then
project onto all of those each time we
will get slightly different means there
are linearly independent perturbations
and now you've got a system of equations
you can assume that the first Gaussian
appears before the second before the
third because your perturbation was very
small now we're left with the problem
with solving in 1d you still have
problems on 1d that turns out to be
quite non-trivial the idea of using
random projection is now quite general
you can use it for supervised learning
as well to reduce sample complexity and
so on when there are margins for example
so to do it in 1d here's another piece
and already realised that you know once
you have a finite number of moments if
you can come up with a Gaussian mixture
so that it agrees with the sample on a
finite number of moments in the first
moment second moment tournament some
finite number then you you you will have
uniquely identified it and sort of the
key result in this column or a value in
paper
is that six moment suffice if you can
match it on six moment yes reserve
distances you project all the way to one
narration you won't preserve every pair
but all we care about are the means
because that's all you track the means
and the covariance matrix which is you
know N squared times K information you
can take more samples than that and and
yes that's right
no sup no this is just learning so yeah
we're really learning because it's a
learning online when I write do any of
these results so the the data points are
coming one at a time perhaps let's see
you can certainly do things like random
projection online because it's data
independent now but then there is a part
where you are solving these linear
systems I don't know I'll have to think
about it yeah
Alliance means so lucky suppression is
smaller we need a smaller education too
right yes so so it depends on the
epsilon that you're assuming for those
two but you know you could even have to
some of the cousins have exactly the
same mean right
so they after all you're gonna learn you
want to learn to some epsilon okay that
means you want to learn each parameter
the means the variances to true to the
epsilon if the means are closer than
that epsilon I don't care if they've
switched yes no no you don't you don't
know success for two gaussians so it
grows with the number of components yes
I think the the the precise it's it's
still it's still unknown what the right
answer is six we can show you can do
better than that
but I believe it's polynomial in no no
no you know does anybody know the answer
is it I'll have to III don't wanna give
you the wrong answer whether it's a
[Laughter]
yeah my only question is is it
polynomial in K or exponential in K the
number of months with K and I want to
say it's polynomial but but but let me
check yeah yes which in this case is six
probably is going to appear in the
exponent of something like the number of
samples you need yes so even six is very
big number because it means like
something okay good good it is
polynomial in K what can you do
yes because this number is an x-phone
that that's all anything good yeah
because you know to compute the cat
moment you need n to the K 2 to the K
type of samples it even in one dimension
okay now that was the first part right
okay so this was doable but with this
huge cost both samples data and and
computation so let's start assuming that
the means are separated you know that
the gaussians are actually pulled apart
someone you say what assume means are
separated and then I'll discuss this in
more detail or you could assume
something weaker that each Gaussian is
separated from the span of the rest you
don't have to be that every pair is far
away or or perhaps even weaker these are
assumptions under which there are
interesting provable results that the
matrix of of means has a bounded
smallest singular value in other words
they're not linearly dependent now the
the means that are not all lying in a
lower dimensional space or close to one
okay so the techniques for this when you
assume separation are basically
principal component analysis and various
guises just use it use it twice or a
weight and use it you will see what I
mean by this
and so since many if you have probably
used for a so component douses at some
point here's some a couple of things we
can actually prove using it for for for
unsupervised learning so just to remind
you of points in high dimensional space
again or do
mean by principle component analysis you
know the first mention component is the
one-dimensional line through the origin
that simply minimizes the sum of squared
distances so that's that's interesting
and perhaps not so commonly known way to
think about it if I have a whole bunch
of points and whatever dimensional space
and I want to know what's the top
principal component of this it's going
to be the single line through the origin
that minimizes the sum of squared
distances that's the top times per
component and then the second one will
be the line orthogonal to this that does
the same thing and so on so now this
this gives us a couple of things the
fact that it's the sum of squares first
that you can use a greedy algorithm to
find the best K dimensional subspace
where you find the best one a project
orthogonal to that find the next best
one and so on
and you can compute this very
efficiently to a singular value
decomposition it's sort of the one of
the core components of numerical
analysis doing this very efficiently and
it's been done for decades now okay so
just to have a picture for a Gaussian
the principal components will be the
axis of this ellipsoid right now why why
do you want to do it well of course it
reduces space because you're going to K
dimension sensitive n dimensions okay if
you're using K components but sometimes
it reveals interesting structure so
that's perhaps yes we will solve the
Gaussian McCann's k yeah separated yes
under waste assumptions using variants
of this exactly yeah
still with the Gaussian mixture problem
so it has a history for centuries and
it's used everywhere all kinds of fields
even the hippocampus I'm doing
but the the the so so let before we use
PCA let's try something more naive just
based on distances now you think that
points you know if you're in one
decision points from one Gaussian should
be closer to each other than points from
another Gaussian in principle and then
what you could do is pick a point take
all the points near it that's one
cluster and then pick another point all
the points near it's another cluster
there's your clustering algorithm but
the trouble is that the separation that
you need for such an algorithm that's
purely looking at distances not the
specific woman any algorithm that only
looks at distances pairwise distances
goes with the dimension it grows as a
polynomial in the damage so even though
you just have two gaussians that are
said that you know that all you need is
separation that's basically the standard
deviation in that direction if you only
use pairwise distances you'll need
separation that's roughly end to the
quarter times the standard deviation and
you can't avoid it so just using
distances cannot work so the idea is
let's project to the top K principal
components for K Gaussian mixture and
then apply distance based classification
why should this do any better so now
instead of separation that grows as the
N to the corner if you preserve this you
know what the algorithm will do is that
the separation will only grow as k to
the corner where K is the number of
gussets
so rather than the ambient dimension
it's the number of components that that
tells you what this is this is for
spherical gaussians and the key
observation here that makes this
possible is that you know suppose you're
talking about just two gaussians you
know the two gaussians the only thing I
need to tell you is the line joining the
means if I were to tell you the line
joining the means you would project the
gaussians to that line and then you have
these two one-dimensional gaussians that
are separated and you'd solve the
problem how do you find this line well
it's the it's the line is the span of
their means right the two means was the
line joining the means let's say the
origin two
if you have K Guardians I'd like to know
the the K dimensional span of the K
means because then you could project
there clearly the distance between the
means will not change meanwhile your
gaussians which are n-dimensional and
huge every pair of points is really far
away are now shrinking down to K
dimensional gossips okay that would be
great how do I find this subspace
spanning the means PCA just take the top
K principal components nothing else and
then since since crystals didn't use any
of his proof credits aloo proof okay so
if I had just one gaussian what would be
the single best line I have one Gaussian
space somewhere and I want to find the
single best line the line that minimizes
the sum of square distance is what will
it be
so you know but but who it will be the
line through the through it's mean right
just by symmetry it's for exhaustion
it'll be the line so it's mean
great so that's that's what we see over
you what would be the best K dimensional
subspace for a single Gaussian it's only
one Gaussian still but I want the best K
dimensional subspace so I get to pick
you know not one but say two three K
what will be the best one yeah what will
it be I have one Gaussian sitting there
it's vertical
here is the origin what should I pick
any K dimensional subspace going through
the origin right there's lots of them
any K is going to the origin that's the
best you could do for one great what is
the best for K gaussians each one of
them wants this subspace to go through
there mean when you've got K dimensions
so you can go through all their means so
that's the answer it will go through all
their means and once it goes through all
their means you're in great shape
because now you project there and your
cousins shrink and now your distances
that you need is only K to the 1/4 no no
this this algorithm would not be useful
would not be interesting
otherwise but oh is there any
mathematical fundamental no but probably
in practice you could argue that models
that have fewer components are more
interesting but but certainly the case
when there are lots of components is
also interesting
yes so far yes yes it works slightly
more generally yeah I took that slide
out what you need is not that they're
Gaussian semen but that their covariance
matrix is is a multiple of identity so
you need the distribution to look like a
white and they correlated distribution
each of the components okay now you
could do this more generally without
this assumption that of circle doesn't
let's say general gaussians but then the
separation that you need for this type
of you know PC based algorithm to work
gross
still k but it grows with the largest
standard deviation of the disease not
the you know spherical doesn't there's
only one here it grows with the largest
one okay so in other words you have to
basically draw a ball around each
Gaussian and these balls should mostly
not over that's that's that's what you
need for this now there is work just to
mention since k-means comes up so much
it's used a lot in heuristic way this is
one of few theorems that i know about it
you could do the same thing apply PCA
and then rather than running this
distance pasting use a k-means type out
in case you haven't seen k-means is this
we want to cluster a set of points you
start with some clustering partition
each of the parts computes their mean
those are the means
now you reassign the points to the
closest mean okay and then recompute the
center's repeat this till it stabilizes
used a lot we people analyze how many
iterations very hard to say anything
about the quality of what you get except
in this case but under some assumptions
that i won't mention these are
deterministic assumptions nothing to do
with doesn't have to be Gaussian
mixtures you have to assume something
about points and how far apart their
means are this method actually converges
and gives you the right clustering it's
proved my kernel and Kumar and it's
crucial that they apply the PCA before
running the k-means
if you just apply PCA on this original
data it doesn't work what if you apply
PCA minute prob'ly works
okay so first PC doesn't work all that
and most of the family doesn't work and
here's why it's not a fine invariant of
course and it's trying to pick the long
directions so what I mean by that is
like in this example if you have
garson's like that that are clearly
separated but in a direction in which
they're narrow now what happens in this
case what will be the top principal
component it's trying to it's the line
that minimizes the sum of squared
distances so it'll be a line like this
and so in fact you'll start picking up
those doesn't help what you want is a
line like this so that when I project
there I get I get these two separated so
just by squeezing them you can just try
you CA so if your data had a linear
transformation applied to it no good
anymore and it's not nice tolerant
either to destroy pca completely for
sure using K component you just need K
bad K strategically placed points they
can completely destroy so both of these
are serious
Lexi within not only from your sign but
even in machine learning and so
situation like this where it works once
you transform it to this it doesn't work
so what however the right assumption in
some sense is not that they are the
means are separated because that's not a
fine invariant but that the components
are probably strictly separated in other
words the probability that a given point
is from one Gaussian dominates it's it's
most very likely it's from this Gaussian
and then will tiny bubble is it might be
from the others so the overlap of the
actual probability densities is
extremely small that's that's the
assumption which which which remains
true with that is a property that's a
fine invariant right you squeeze you
doesn't change the fact that the
probability distributions don't overlap
so it seems to be the right thing PCA is
not so here is an isotropic or fine
invariant version of this eh
the first step is make the distribution
of finding women what by that I mean
make it isotropic so take your
distribution the data whatever it is
compute its covariance matrix
maybe the covariance matrix is is not is
not spherical convert it to a spherical
covariance matrix so your data gets
transformed so now your covariance is
identity pca by itself will tell you
nothing and then you're going to real
weight points so that points that are
further away get lesser and lesser
weight just the weights are themselves
are Gaussian and now you see has your
mean shifted because you've rebated if
it has that direction is going to be
very important you'll use it to cut and
recurse if the mean hasn't shifted maybe
because they are balanced components
take the top principal component project
on that and reverse so it's a
combination of pca in and this recursive
transformation and just to show you what
does isotropic transformation do you
know these are separated but very narrow
so of course it pulls them apart these
look like this they're narrow in other
directions it makes this is just
whitening as some people call it or the
correlation okay now so it does this but
now you're done you can't use pc anymore
right every direction is the same
equally good my definition so and this
is what i just described
if some component is heavier then
they're new mean shifts along the
separating direction and if if not the
related principal component is along a
separating direction this is provable if
you have a mixture of k arbitrary
gaussians now under the assumption that
each one is separated from the span of
the rest
this algorithm recursive algorithm
actually works and it's polynomial in n
k and their operators it's not clear if
we can extend this to something more
general than mixtures of gaussians
specifically for mixes unconscious
the means justify the means each mean is
separated from the span of the other
means so to show you these are mixtures
of gaussians the experiments you can
trust you can generate Gaussian trust
them so here's the original data it's in
40 dimensions but I you know projected
to do I am picking showing you the true
dimensions in which the means were
separated of course the algorithm
doesn't know that so if you do a random
projection of course everything gets
combined if I do a principle component
is no better I mean looks maybe worse
and then if you do this sort of PCA
it'll pull them apart okay so just to
finish off this module or this section
an extension that's important that I
haven't dealt with is learning noisy
distribution so what if your data is
mostly from a Gaussian or mostly from a
mixture but 1% is not what can you do
I enjoy this agnostic learning and of
course it's of interest and supervised
learning as well and in in recent work
or past a couple of years for many of
these problems the answer is yes for
others it's still open
there have been some developments on how
you can remove our pliers now you can
deal with arbitrary noise small levels
of it in these type of generative models
so if the problem is already interesting
even for one Gaussian suppose your data
is coming ninety ninety percent from one
Gaussian in ten percent arbitrary okay
you want to estimate the mean and
variance of the true original Gaussian
so if your noise rate is some beta you
can estimate the mean to within a ten
times the standard deviation and you can
do it polynomial time and that's the
best you could do with any hours
yeah for mixtures it's still not clear
there are algorithms that I presented to
you don't quite extend yet but that
could be a matter of we don't fully
understand it it is no lower bound
okay so we're finished the first one in
case you're worried this will go faster
I thought I should do the first one in
some detail so algorithm the type of
analysis so we'll go to a second model
for unsupervised learning which has
shown up a lot and actually multiple
times in neuroscience analyzing various
things including fMRI data so here's the
model you start with the product
distribution so there's a bunch of
variables and each variable value was
generated independently from some
distribution let's say in this case an
interval and then there's a linear
transformation applied but you don't
know this transformation transformation
and then you're given the data so what
you're saying is a linear transfer
molding a transformation of a product
distribution and so points from some
unknown in this case parallelepiped but
it could be something else and their
problem is find this transformation like
what was the transformation that led to
you seeing this data yeah it's a product
product of one dimension distributions
that's the yeah now can this problem be
solved I mean is it actually well posed
I mean in general no right what if the
components were gaussians and the
transformation was the rotation then of
course not because rotate Gaussian looks
the same but that is the only way you it
might not be well posed so oh by the way
there's a more general version is that
it doesn't just have to be a linear
transformation could be a full
dimensional one it could be any linear
transmission so it could be included
projection so this data in this space
that that I rotated and then projected
on to some lower dimensional space and
you're only seeing the lower dimension
projection of it so the matrix a doesn't
have to be square or full rank okay
so this is the problem there is your
original data s in some space then there
is this matrix a possibly mapping to a
different space and you're seeing this
data X and the components of s are
generated independently
so the theorem right for identifiability
is that this translation is unique up to
sines of the columns columns if you
negate the entire column you can tell
anything as long as at most one of these
components is gaussian if two components
are gaussian again you're in trouble
right you will never be able to set tell
those apart because you could just
rotate in that two dimension space you
won't be able to tell them apart but as
long as all but one or not gaussian or
maybe all are not gaussian then it's
uniquely R in fab you can figure it out
yes try to learn what the original
distribution was just the transformation
but then that allows you to pull apart
the statistics of any one coordinate and
then you know it depends how you want to
learn the distribution main various
moments identifying the parameters
rather than coming up with the
distribution that is close to this right
right in this case though once you've
figured out the matrix a yeah okay
that but you're right if we're trying to
figure out what is this this hidden
model a that that's transforming your
original later there's no probability
here because you know there is no data
involved in this statement it's like
saying gaussians are uniquely
identifiable yeah of course things can
go wrong if you applied any particular
sample but but the parameters cannot be
from two different so there are no two
different matrices a1 and a2 which will
give you the same distribution yeah so
this has been used for a long time
there's a famous paper by Bell and
saharsky which does expectation
maximization for this and they get good
results and some practical scenarios
apparently it's part of the Semarang
software routinely and so on there are
many attractive heuristics it's kind of
a fun problem how would you do this but
and but now relatively recently we have
provable guarantees so the most general
thing is that as long as the columns of
a satisfy a weak linear independence
condition it's much weaker than linear
independence
could be I'll tell you many qualities
and the components are some distance
from Gaussian when I said not Gaussian
of course if you be closer and closer
and closer to gaussian it'll be less and
less identifiable so the problem has to
depend on how close to gaussian you are
and then you have to ask how do you
measure the distance to gaussian so
these are all questions but the point is
that as long as you are at some distance
from gaussian you can and and you assume
that the original matrix has some weak
linear independence property you'll be
able to figure out the matrix up to any
desired Epsilon and what do I mean by
generalized linear independence you take
a matrix a assume it has distinct
columns not necessarily linear dependent
but just distinct now find the smallest
power right and by power I mean take
each column so if you have the column a
1 you replace it by a 1 outer product a
1 think of that as a columnar and so on
so just growing in sizes every time now
at some point as if you start with
distinct columns this will become
linearly independent you might have to
go as many times as the number of
columns but it will become independent
and look at the smallest dimension at
which it becomes really independent
that's not suffice
that's the D that's used so now for D
equal to 1 which just means that you
assume the columns are actually
independent this is the case that's most
widely studied start using your matrix a
is independent that's already been yeah
yeah there's a this Polly includes D and
thinking of as a constant but that
polynomial allows exponents in of D yeah
it's like it's an exponent yeah so it's
M to the deep
now D equal to 1 linearly independent
case I'll go to the techniques in a
minute but already PC a no chance and
because the matrix a could have been a
rotation and then you get nothing from
it let's skip this this works with
Gaussian noise and in very recent work
it actually works with a small amount of
arbitrary noise the techniques maybe
maybe this is interesting
PCA is useless because it could be a
rotation but the following view or
generalization of it is useful if you
think of pca as maximizing second
moments it's the direction that
maximizes the second moment of
distribution it's the second moments
maximize a higher moment make the fourth
moment now that's a hard problem second
moments great easy we can do it in
polynomial time
just fourth moment in general point
since it's a hard problem even to
approximate however for this problem
it's sufficient to go to any local
optima in fact the local optima are
going to be exactly the vectors along
the columns of a if a is linearly
dependent so this was already proven by
frieze German Canon and and the point is
that you can think of this as a
particular case of tensor decomposition
and that leads to the more general
algorithm but but basically you're going
to local optima of higher moments and
even the local optima are already useful
because you assume such structure in the
in the in the in the in the data ok so
that's that's where we are now by the
way sorry I'm leaving room for questions
you're welcome to ask more yeah
the next topic mind is finding planted
structures I think this is also and then
we'll Sigler clustering okay so plan we
saw click in the morning as an instance
of an np-complete problem but also as
one that's hard to optimize you kind of
approximate the clip to an nearly linear
fact in the dimension right so there
might exist a clique of size constant
time then and you can't even find one of
size n over log cuban right now and
probably not even n over two to the root
log n so very hard to optimize what if
the graph was random
just random Jim can you find the largest
clique in this you know crystal said
that he knows this graph intimately I
will challenge him to find the largest
clique
he knows the size you know said sighs he
knows the height of his friend but not
what it looks like
so okay so so it's it's it's to log in
to log in but we the best algorithms we
know can only find a clique of size log
in and one of those is just take the
largest degree and largest degree and
largest degree and go as far as long as
you can go till you have a clique that
gives you logon we can kind of do better
than two we don't know how to find two
log n ok maybe this is a mathematical
game what if I plant in a random graph a
much larger click to logon is the
largest you'd expect you can find with
high probably there won't be one legend
that let me plant a small of size K
where K is much larger probabilistic and
we don't know so so what is the problem
the problem is I give you a random graph
and with high probability over the
choice of the random graph I would like
you to output a clique of size two log
it I'll be happy if you go one point
zero one log N and we don't know how to
do this
there is no hardness statement there is
no hardness known
yeah in polynomial time if you allow me
enter the login time it's easy yeah
or anything less than into the login so
let's make it a little easier and maybe
more relevant in stuff just pure random
graph suppose there are there's a large
clique in there that was planted that
were said in some place and you would
like to know find it or at least detect
that it's there
okay so what is the size at which you'll
be able to do this and how do you do it
so that's the planted clique problem now
similarly you can ask other ones take a
random graph introduce a partition you
know where the density is lesser than
the density and the rest can you find
this partition right again that's a hard
problem worst case planted assignment so
there's a constraint satisfaction
problem Laura satisfiability problem and
you've seeing all these clauses and the
clauses are random but they are
consistent with some assignment okay you
can you detect this and can you can you
find the find the find the assignment
and then you could plant other things I
mean you can plant all kinds of things
it's sort of a a way to model a problem
yeah now here's the status for plank
clicks the end of the login is easy just
find you know this brute force search if
K is large enough if K is actually Omega
root n then you can do it in polynomial
time any constant constant can be any
constant you can do in Palo Alto and I
will see this algorithm original you do
a long tribulation to the code and now
it turns out that if K is a little bit
less than root n then at least for
statistical algorithms which I still
haven't defined the complexity is n to
the log N
if somebody finds an algorithm it will
be very interesting only statistical for
once for one so is there a polynomial
algorithm for K any K less than root n
root n over log n I'm serious and asking
a neuroscientist I mean they've solved
multiple problems so this is anybody's
game
so techniques how many toriel this is
the heck
another reason speed sorry problems in
this field so after all these algorithms
are doing it for Omega root n here is
Phi J's algorithm he said just remove
the lowest degree vertex repeatedly so
remove the smallest vertex look at the
remaining girls - did you repeat this
till you get up - well if to be a little
bit careful at the end you get to about
2k and then you have to do something
extra but but basically that's the other
but you can also do spectrally as an
original paper so take the principal
components of this of the adjacency
matrix which you build by putting a what
I mean let's say 1 4 edges and minus 1 4
no edges do you know the graph put a one
rather than edge minus one where there
is no edge and so what you see this is
the sample that you see this is the
graph that you see looks like a clique
that's planted there plus a random graph
that's what it looks like and so and the
idea here is just basically take the top
principal component and take the highest
entries of that and that will be mostly
the clique and then from those you can
build the rest why is that so
fundamental theorem of fluid in Kailash
miss signal but it says that the for
pure random matrix burn only but that
theorem is much more general any matrix
with independent entries and and say
bounded variance the top eigenvalue and
the spectral norm is 2 square root n so
a random matrix doesn't contribute much
to the energy or to the top principal
component from a matrix so as long as
your Klink this part
have top principle component as much of
the size of pick if this is all once
here K by K the eigenvalues K so if K is
larger than root n or two root n you win
you'll start seeing that that's the game
okay but that's basically the best known
algorithm similarly there's a similar
story for planted satisfiability or
constraint satisfaction problems on even
subsets of K variables at a time K
literals at a time information
theoretically analog and clauses suffice
you know once you have any login clauses
the assignment that could be consistent
with these random clauses is unique
however the best algorithms today
require n to the K over 2 plus huge gap
right these are not anything complete
problems because random instances
there's no we're in the random setting
here so how do I explain this gap the
information theoretically n log n if you
give me exponential time I can figure it
out right because I try all 2 to the N
assignments but but algorithmically the
best we know is n to the K out now it
turns out that for statistical
algorithms it's almost that the lower
bound up to a log log n inside the
exponent fact so again is there a faster
method to detect whether there's a
planted assignment and this is something
that the the algorithms have have come
from physicists and very interesting
ones ok so here's the one slide to slide
version of why what are we talking about
status signals because there is some
chance that they are relevant to the
brain anything could be so so the idea
is just that instead of seeing
explicitly examples so let's say a
learning problem you don't get to
explicitly see the examples whether it's
supervised or unsupervised you don't get
to see the examples explicitly rather
you can ask for the expectation of a
function or for the function evaluated
on a random example
so and so these are modeled by various
Oracle's we don't need to do the details
right now but basically suppose I have
all these examples that I want to know
what is the average first coordinate I
can ask that and I'll get back an error
within some tolerance or I could ask if
I were to take an example a random
example and multiply it by this intake
the inner product with a particular
vector V so the expectation of X dot me
give me that value to within some
epsilon you can do that once you can do
this you can do all kinds of algorithms
there's only one that I know which is
actually useful for salsa nice problem
that we don't know how to do in this
model and probably cannot be done and
that's Gaussian elimination over finite
fields not over the reals or finite
fields so if you wanted to solve linear
equations mod 2 and you're getting
examples from some distribution you can
solve I mean maybe have to be careful
how you define the problem you can do
convex programming the point is that
it's it's the problem has to be over
distributions right because you're
asking for a function of distributions
suppose you're talking about stochastic
stochastic convex optimization so some
stochastic function where the objective
function is an expectation over excess
from some distribution there's a convex
set there yeah you can do that it
depends on yeah yeah it does give some
results so this is a technical question
[Music]
what it implies is that for example
let's say the satisfiability problem
over here a KKK set for distributions
what it implies is that the dimension
okay of any convex program that can
solve them so independent of service
will query must be at least in this case
we can prove n to the K over 2
okay so so these are these discussed
problems I think it's relevant could be
interesting to define these there's
potential for lots of algorithms but
also lower bounds and now I'm at
clustering you have the appetite for one
more topic and so what is clustering
yeah you know you want to divide into
things that are similar this is again a
huge field lots of experts and what
could the output be could just be a
partition it could be a hierarchical
clustering and maybe for each cluster
you also provide a list of features that
distinguish that cluster from the rest
and so on so the typical approaches are
to optimize it some objective function
this has led to some very nice problems
and results so it could be the k-means
objective function which means that each
cluster has a center and you're trying
to minimize the sum of squared distances
of the data points to their nearest
center that's okay means objective
function but maybe you want to minimize
the diameter of the minimize the maximum
diameter of the clusters that you find
or so on and these these problems
typically are already np-complete and be
hard in the worst case mmm and even hard
to proximate but they've led to some
very nice approximation of those and
techniques which might work better on
real data then the worst case suggests
another approach is axiomatic where you
assume some assumptions on what it means
for a clustering to be valid or the
right one something about the ground
truth so to speak and then you give
algorithms that find that given the data
and then of course you can just apply
one of these methods that's very general
like the k-means algorithm either or not
you want to use their k-means objective
function you always use the k-means
algorithm or you could use the m and in
other ways and so on we have to
understand how good is the solution how
efficient is the method and so on
perhaps most importantly whether the
clustering that you find is of any
relevance is is it the right one for
this domain yeah I mentioned this
already so here's a one sort of general
approach you of this graph which is
encoding pairwise similarity
let's say the weight on the edge tells
you how similar they are a and B are and
so let's partition this addition
partition partition you've got this tree
built up where the root is the entire
graph and the leaves are the individual
nodes and then given this recursive
partition this partition let's find an
optimal tree respecting clustering you
know one that your clusters have to be
sub trees of this why well because it's
easier to optimize over trees and lots
of things are much easier over trees to
do dynamic programming so this is the
general approach you start you divide
and then you might do some merge or you
might basically stop dividing at some
point and that's those are your clusters
in other words okay so but then the
question becomes how do you cut what's
the right way to partition there's no
John of course there is no Universal
answer you could use a minimum cut the
one that seems to be particularly
interesting is the sparse cart or
minimum expansion cut so I spend this
this segment of time on that so in case
you haven't seen it you have this graph
and so the expansion of a subset is the
is measuring its neighborhood size
relative to its size and if you have
weighted edges conductance and it's the
total weight from the subset to its
complement divided by the smaller of the
total weight incident to this subset and
its complement so you're measuring
weight across divided by total weight
yeah that's the conductance and you know
this was already introduced in a very
influential paper in image segmentation
by she'll malloc here and it has lots of
applications out mention is the notion
of conductance an expansion okay so how
to cut now of course this this quantity
is also np-hard
we don't know
nice you can play with it done data if
you like this why why this seems nice
you know it's it's saying you might have
some few were disease that have very
little degree to the rest so you cut
them off but that's not so interesting
if I can get this cut in the middle
which really separates most of the 10%
of the graph from the rest that's very
interesting that's telling you something
so we can't approximate it to within a
factor of log in log of the number of
vertices in the graph using a linear
program to within square root login
using a semi definite program also an
efficiently solvable connect program and
the one that talked about more here is
using eigenvalues where you can get the
classical fiddler card gives you square
root of the art so you don't incur any
log factors then you get square root
yeah and this algorithm is extremely
simple we'll see it a couple of times
take the second largest eigen vector of
a similarity matrix but you have to take
the similarity matrix and normalize it
will tell you how or if you're more
familiar with laplacian switch and used
in a second then you take the second
smallest so this would be the second
larger so there was a second smallest
and in case you sought the sort by the
by the by the value of the component in
this eigenvector so this is the sorted
order smallest to largest say and that
suggests n minus one possible cuts take
the best of those just take the best of
these cuts in this order and that
already gives you a square root of opt
can't be any worse than that
now assuming such a cutting procedure
this this or this any of these what good
is it for this you know you're
repeatedly cutting right not just once
you've been recursively that you'd like
a guarantee for the end result of
clustering not just the cut that was the
original problem so suppose we had a
cutting algorithm that each time instead
giving you the best cut gave you some
constant times to cut to some power just
the general way of writing it then and
you assume that there exists some
clustering alpha epsilon clustering what
do i mean by that that the conductance
of each cluster is at least alpha so
each cluster is
well connected it's very hard to break
off any subset of it without cutting off
lots of edges and moreover no you the
total amount of edges you've cut is
small so you started with maybe I should
draw some things to my heads
you start with something that's a graph
and it's you know what is a good
clustering you can eventually after
cutting and cutting and cutting you'll
come up with some partition here you'd
like that each piece is really well
connected so the conductance within each
piece is at least I have fun and the
total weight of edges that you cut is
that most an epsilon fraction of the
total so you've only sacrificed the
epsilon similarity to get these clusters
that are all very tightly knit that's
that so assuming that exist some alpha
epsilon clustering alpha epsilon numbers
between 0 & 1 then just this recursive
partitioning using whatever library
routine you had for getting one cut at a
time will give you something that's
comparable in in in in conductance to
the existing one and comparable in how
many edges you cut to the existing one
in particular if you do the recursive
spectral partitioning just this Fiedler
rector spectral partitioning you're
gonna get alpha squared over log and
quality of clusters and two square root
epsilon log in for the total number
fraction of edges wasted yes a fraction
of edges and conductance is always
smaller than one because it's the weight
yeah yeah okay so going back to the
expansion statement any any any
questions welcome this was the
definition of of the conductance of a
set and then we had the minimum of the
entire graph and I already mentioned the
complexity from a lower bound side and
from the upper bounds now fantastic open
problem is to prove anything better than
this we don't know if what we are
yes but I can stop now if you so so can
you show that that it's np-hard to
compute this parses cut of this
connections to a factor better than one
point zero one okay
we don't know unlike clique which is
very hard to compute or other problems
for which say a factor of two is
difficult here we don't know one point
zero one okay so eigen values just a
small detour noggin values because this
has become very useful especially in the
segment of algorithms that are seen to
be approaching practicality for large
datasets and so on we have some
adjacency or similarity matrix a it's
weighted and each row has a degree just
a total weight on that row and the one
nice thing to do is to just normalize it
in this way
degree to the square of degree to the
square root and in particular for D
regular graphs so if it's just zero once
where everybody had the same degree in
the beginning this is just scaling to
make the row sums one we're doing it
this way it keeps the matrix symmetric
now the laplacian or normalized
laplacian is sort of negation of this is
the identity - it's convenient to work
with this I didn't even so if you want
to think about this think of a regular
graph although everybody X has the same
degree and so we've normalized it so
every entries 1 over B now and I'm
taking identity - this the diagonal is 1
everywhere off timer for every edge I
have a minus 1 over degree well there
are edges and zeros where there are no
edges that's the matrix now this matrix
is a several nice properties a couple of
them are that the small second value is
0 and it's the smallest so it's a
positive semi definite matrix and the
the eigenvector for 0 is is proportional
to the square root of the degree
now that's this is just saying what the
second eigenvalue is it has this nice
form the second eigenvalue is this ratio
of the difference between the
eigenvector entries at two adjacent
nodes waited and and normalized by sum
of all their squares so okay so this is
just set up know if the second
eigenvalue is also zero it must be the
case that the graph is disconnected
there's no other way if and only if a
graph is connected if and only if lambda
2 is greater than 0 and otherwise it's
okay so then this suggests what if it's
close to zero then does this mean that
it's close to disconnected in other
words is there a small cut that
separates into two components and that's
the fundamental theorem of [ __ ] and a
long Mellman that says that indeed the
conductance this expansion of the cart
is between the second eigenvalue and its
square root so it's really small you
will find a cart conductance is very
small exist but you'll also find it and
here's the other the proof of existence
is through the cells and it's a it's
just sort the components of the second
eigenvector and consider the N minus 1
cuts take the best one and basically
those Cauchy Schwarz in case you know
after this week of wonderful talks
you're itching for a proof complete
proof about the lower bound is easy
because any cut down would you like to
go okay
so so it's usually lots of places this
thing and yeah now you could ask here
just to give a flavor of an extension -
sounds great
I want Kay I don't wanna recursively cut
for K I want to find K because there
exists K in my graph maybe how to define
it the definition itself is not so bad
this mod K way expansion is you know for
each subset suppose I partition into K
subsets for each subset look at the
expansion so I just said go out verses
it and then you take the maximum or the
K subsets and you'd like to minimize
that so find the cut that minimizes the
maximum separation among these you could
define other ways this seems to be the
most natural way now let's go back to to
the parent Rubinius again suppose the
first K eigen well not 2 but K eigen
values of 0 that can only happen if the
graph has at least K connected
components if and only so you okay eigen
value 0 means K connected components so
this suggests what if lambda K is close
to 0 which of course implies that the
other ones are also close to 0 do you
get a nice cut is there a chicken
equality for this question was first
last far as I know to me but my Luca
Trevor's on one of the people running
this Institute and and here's a tip and
says that yes this K way expansion is
also related to the knot to lambda K but
something slightly higher than lambda x
times root loci and this relationship is
tight if K is 2 it's it's a [ __ ] in
equality but but even even in for
general K its type K disjoint subsets
each with small expansion or if you get
lots of subsets with
the index 1.01 king means it is an
integer right yeah yeah what I mean is
that you could be I'm using one point
zero one but it works for any one plus
Epsilon alternatively you can say you
get as many subsets as you wanted a
little bit less but with exactly one
okay so just a high level what do these
algorithms look like because maybe that
guarantee is not so interesting with
algorithm might be first step you want
to embed to the top K eigenvectors
second step and this is another step
that's used a lot in approximation
algorithms in cometary optimization
you're going to we're going to partition
these these the the vertices of a graph
into K ordered sets by randomized
rounding show you that in a second and
then once you get K ordered sets will
apply chiggers algorithm to each of the
subjects so first step is the spectral
embedding and that just means the
following first I've taken the top K
principal components those are the
vertices of the graph the original
roasted matrix and we can think of this
as an embedding right away right that's
what those are the the vectors
representing each row
now you pick random Gaussian vectors
separately and you project each of your
rector's you have now represent a metre
space to do each of these is gaussians
and you're going to assign it to that
Gaussian which maximizes the the
magnitude the closest one in in an to
the better in an angle and that gives
you partitioning and then you just run
cheerson okay so that completes sort of
this selective survey of methods in in
in unsupervised learning for which we
have probable guarantees
yeah otherwise how I see more slides on
a couple of things from recent times yes
there are many ways so one that seems to
come up a lot is the KL divergence which
measures how different they are but you
could you could use more total variation
distance which is maybe more basic it's
just for each point in the support
you're looking at the difference between
the densities assigned and adding up the
absolute value scale the input to all
the algorithms that you've talked about
was either a graph or some sort of point
set which you could do as a degenerate
graph is it always easier obvious to
encode every problem into that kind of
input format or or is it possible that
there are problems where where there's
even a non polynomial step that has to
be done just together into a suitable
form solution I mean these are the
predominant ways to address most
problems but suddenly I don't know the
answer to a question about whether
getting into this formula is sometimes
hard but I do know that there can be
data that doesn't fit in this for
example you graph is changing and you
want to cluster some kind of time
dynamics certainly haven't addressed
that now in principle you should be able
to embed everything as points in in a
sufficiently high dimensional space
whether it's useful to do that is there
is there is a different
but what discussion graphs that changed
I had to boil dynamics yeah
what's sort of the nature of the
temporal dynamics like changes in the
hatchway or addition of nodes yeah both
of those things yeah yeah let me think
of the connectome and maybe you want to
classify the nodes of the connectome
based on their temporal behavior so
there's all this theory no I'm not aware
of to use them in data that we have on
the brain oh you want to say something
that's our brain oh why why this talk
yeah yeah yeah no no it's asked them I
said that multiple times we know so
little about the brain we might as well
talk about something we know something
about you know but the reason is that
methods are perhaps suggestive of what's
possible and what's not possible
now you have the brain is supposed to be
solving all these problems I don't know
precisely what problem with solving
amazing problems and here are some ways
to solve some interesting problems which
are not so far away at least in setup so
okay you're not going to run PCA but you
might run some kind of iteration that
converges to the result of that like we
saw in the end of you know stock where
you know there's this objective function
it's not even convex and bad evil you
shouldn't put possibly potentially do it
because it's just a local search it's
like to use these algorithms from a lot
of data that we have when you're a
science or actually I'm more interested
in the ladder but absolutely use them
for neuroscience yeah
yeah just a comment there to comment on
this I mean the I think that two kind of
hidden assumptions in the results one
type of results a result that deserves
some general some some some personal
data you assume that the data is
partitioned well with small cuts there
is no reason to believe that natural
data has this problem and to get
provable results you have to make this
assumption the other big question mark
is is the objective the real objective
that you care about to cluster because
if you cluster with one objective in
your class there is another way you get
completely different partitions and
again all these work is you assume one
objective and then you investigate how
to reach it but there's not much work on
which object it is suitable for your
typing probably can only do this online
right they can run several thousands of
data do these kind of models do these
count these kinds of algorithms like
simple circuits simple neuro artificial
ones I mean you can implement any of
these in Hardware most of them are
iterative so there are simple loops
that's one of the common features of all
of these things even the tensor methods
and so on they they tend to be traded so
you know there's a yeah but but yeah we
certainly the neural circuits to compute
I see a sparse coding is basically doing
so you can all do that with happy alarms
is a backwards on the brain
same with mixture of gaussians make sure
mixture models at least you could think
of that in terms of like winner-take-all
burning that's kind of poor man's
version of the play neural networks that
can do kind of learn categories of a
different nature you have to know on
then data you have no guarantee but they
come from and now the question is now
how good is the approximation going to
be then right no I think I don't see how
to use provable things or even how to
formulate questions about this I mean
there is online clustering there's a
there's actually much literature on this
because of the streaming model you can
put a sense where you really assume data
is coming in a stream and let's say you
want to do k-means or comedian on data
that's just coming in a string you don't
even you know you really know what order
it's gonna come in and you'd still
nevertheless at any point in at any
point in the stream you want to maintain
k coins which are meant to be as good as
the k-means not close to the best
k-means for the data so far and this is
their approval guarantees for the
guarantees on the data so far the
algorithm is constrained to be small
memory streaming yes there's a lot of
literature on this this type of yeah if
you want to maintain a clustering on
line with small memory
the problem of missing data so these
algorithms in a static way so you're
recording from some subset of neurons
one is a one file some other subsets
yeah it's a good question the techniques
yes
the these models on capital exactly that
but you know we have this matrix
completion and problems which are
exactly the type of thing you're asking
about you have some matrix you see some
entries and you'd like to use the rest
or they'll use some property of the rest
and matter for the net flix problem
stress up all the time matrix
factorization in matrix completion and
the for these problems similar
techniques are used in fact the early
ones for matrix completion just use a
variant of spectral methods now they are
based on some assumptions so you have to
assume for example typical assumption is
that the matrix from which you're seeing
only few increases low rank or close to
low rank of course you need to make some
assumption otherwise every entry could
be how much does the algorithm change
stability and robustness in at least me
personally about that I'm using an
algorithm something like ICA and then I
want to add I don't know some extra
smooth this assumption in time for
example I'm an under components transfer
and I don't know really how to easily
change the algorithms which is going to
probably isn't yes no it's it's a good
question yeah I don't have a general
answer certainly the they're you know
agnostic learning is one attempt at this
for some of the data is
so Weekend Update oh yeah online PC yeah
but I think he's asking what if you
change the assumptions of the problem so
your cost function completely changes
from do you start over can you use the
solution that you have from like a
simple I see as a good decision for me
iiiiii would want to give you a general
answer yeah I I would bet there are
problems for which is such a small
change make this transform them to
really hard and others for which you
know noise of certain types of changes
certain types go through a court check
this has always meant it's like in two
dimensions where are you trying to get
higher dimensions on to the two and then
the e up some I dare you want to tile
this space but you want the
interconnections between similar neurons
with similar properties to be small
that's I guess the feeling I just wonder
if if that ever falls into your
bailiwick of Ezard because it seems like
it would be over so some pairs you want
them to be closer than other pairs yeah
you for example you have these
orientation cells yes yes so what find
embedding that preserves two-dimensional
space tiles but then you have to fit all
the orientations and then seems like
graph embedding problem yes certainly
there's work on trying to embed
distances you've got this graph let's
think of what you're saying as distance
is you know these are closer these are
farther and so on between neurons and
you'd like to now realize this in a low
dimensional space so that the resulting
embedding preserves these distances yeah
this this is this is a subject of much
work distance preserving embeddings and
of course as usual we know things about
what's the worst case you know
distortion that you might suffer or how
well can you approximate but for for
yeah somebody the letter there a lot of
the thinking is that you're trying to
save wires and so you're gonna connect
like Paris are you trying to tile it in
a way that saves wires but I think I
don't know I've been in neurobiology
that's actually known to the extend of
the wire cost of what's connected to
what and so it could it could be a
formal problem I'm one Greek I just no
no no no no it did they doesn't it
parameter yeah you're willing to connect
to you'll get different and beddings and
it seems I'm just trying to be friendly
no I would bet that the specific the
most immediate not realized it so it's
nice we could take us through this
exercise so he's saying you know you
want to take this graph basically which
represents the neurons and their and
their similarities and embed them in 2d
with the additional constraint that you
minimize let's say the total wire
lengths or or maybe just directly try to
keep things that are closer closer in
the embedding so I'm gonna see if I won
if someone you and then will tell me
what the I'm just okay as a function of
the observed data yeah so the starting
point I mean you can probably safely
assume this problem is np-hard
probably or we can tell crystals to do
it by tomorrow because this but but but
that's not that's not that's no good
that's no good I agree so then in in log
in dimension he wants to D right I mean
if you could do this in 2d we can solve
Max Cutler I mean 3d isn't it
but it makes it property to preserve
yeah somewhere no no it's a great
question and if you come up with the
right heuristic who cares if what
happens in the West case right person
any kind of work in in physics model
just a slight perturbation of the input
the optim-ox cop is one of the nicest
example that's able to look at a random
graph you like taking marks car it's an
optimal solution you've perturbed the
random graph a little bit the new
optimal solution is completely different
so this another of process is actually
quite related to the complexity in
finding the optimal solution so it's
done remember there is another example
of this so if you think of the case of
the objective function that you want to
change them to let's say by like your
penalty smoothly let's say by increasing
the penalty gradually right then the
solution will take a path that you can
prove in some cases it is continuous for
example in compressors if you increase
the l1 penalty there is this homotopy
method right that justin Romberg has
introduced that you can that basically
gives you the solution path going from
the original objective function that you
had plus like the penalty gradually how
it changes so I was one thing when I
asked the question I was wondering if
there's
similar let's say for I see it right
into the obstacles precisely what the
complexity of the problem kicks in in
some sense in the compressor so my
question is what about graph clustering
problem so the trough is so big you
cannot even write down yes there are
there serious efforts to to do it does
this but this is a familiar problem like
with the internet or the at different
levels and so on so people have to talk
about a local graph clustering or where
the idea is that you're exploring a
graph and all you are able to keep in
memory is some small number of nodes and
edges and so based and of course other
statistics based on this you want to
decide when to cut off thesis and call
it a cluster and so on so this is a
certainly a topic of let's our results
there are so there is some there is some
very nice theory so for example
algorithms like PageRank which Google
uses and related ones there are local
versions of these which to the extent
that portal improve our PageRank you can
almost prove
so I guess I was wondering if if it
turns out that the brain and neural
circuits are using one of these methods
to do some sort of computation you
Illustrated a number of situations where
the algorithm breaks down and you start
to like lose the ability to compute yes
are there corresponding like psycho
cycle on you can maybe think of like try
to explore whether or not those are
valid properties that make sense yeah
yeah inputs that just break the
algorithm you somebody pushes you off
the cliff and that's it
clearly you're not interested in my
neural effort so let's continue so I
think we are at 3 o clock so I will just
flash through these slides the one I
want to say is a paper with crystals
where we introduce this notion called
predictor joint which represents
something that fires when both a and B
fired but by just building this in a
sort of decentralized brainless way it
then creates high-level concepts which
fire exactly when the same pattern that
fired in when it was created is
presented okay so it's a very quick
summary and it allows you to share
substructures when you build multiple
paths when you're memorizing multiple
patterns probably what's important here
may be interesting here is that learning
happens quickly sharing as we predict
but emit the majority of the traffic in
this algorithm is downwards now there's
this question of why is feedback useful
at all and to solve even just
memorization of n bit patterns seems
that that downward our feedback is
crucial I guess we do not Road without
it and the basic unit we're suggesting
is a unit that if a and B fire it
but if only one of them fires it looks
for the other one it predicts it
predicts the other one yeah okay and the
last one this I'll skip forward this is
the extension of that to learning
thresholds they can be hierarchical oh
it could be simultaneous I mean a
pattern okay then the last thing is
something that sort of inspired by the
connectome
now we've seen these random models we
saw J and P and then there are very nice
extensions to this power law graphs and
small world networks that explain things
about things like the internet and
social networks one thing they don't
seem to capture is the clustering
coefficient and the probability that
neighbors are a little more likely to be
connected and for this I want to mention
give you a one slide of the new model
but before that you know this is
relevant to neuroscience like Christo's
mentioned this paper you know this is
about highly non-random features in the
connectivity and so you know they find
that things like reverse connections and
triangles of various types are much more
likely than you would get in a random
graph random electrical so we need these
models one nice thing here again from
the theoreticians perspective is that no
you know generalization of a single
random graph like a stochastic block
model can do this its size must grow
with the with the size of the graph
linear in the size of the graph so you
can't capture it with you can't get both
triangles and number of edges correct if
you use a stochastic block not even for
a hyper graph this is a fool statement
unless you use the block model
proportional to the size of the number
of vertices however here is a very
simple extension of GNP you build a
random graph you build a graph in this
model by picking random subsets of
vertices and placing a random graph on
them but these are going to be slightly
denser so it's a union of relatively
dense random sub graphs with this
you can get clustering coefficients to
vary as you want while capturing degree
distributions and in particular the
notion that higher degree vertices are
in fewer triangles so the chance that
higher degree vertices have common
neighbors is slower than that of lower
degree vertices that happens you know
GNP it's flat probability of them being
joined is independent of the majority
degree but you get that in this
[Applause]
[Applause]